when you come around that corner and you
put that move on that alignment and
you're turning and he's squared up in
that pocket you know you can't hear
anything at this point right it's like
you in a a tunnel and it's just like
that it's quiet yeah and when you hit
him and drop and you hear that from him
that's the first thing you hear the ooh
from heaven when you open your eyes or
you look up it's like somebody just like
took headphones off of you and the crowd
is there and chill but arguing them now
foreign
you're such a physically big tough guy
that you can just manhandle people and
were you a big guy in high school
you know I was a short fat kid and when
I was in like grammar school and then
like I got picked on a lot but I was
like always the wise-ass kid you know
like you'd beat me up and stuff then I'd
run like 50 yards turn around flip you
to Bear bird and like try to run away
and get beat up again and then as as
time went on I got bigger and bigger and
bigger and then those kids I wouldn't
run anymore they would run it would like
that and when do you start to excel at
sports weren't you a wrestler or
something yeah yeah I was a state champ
in New Jersey wrestling wrestling is the
hardest sport isn't it I mean real
legitimate wrestling it is it is it's
it's let me tell you something and being
you know you can be in the best shape
ever the best football shape ever right
and uh you'd like go out there the first
day you think I'm in pretty good shape
you know I've been playing football for
like you know three four months and all
of a sudden you get in there and you're
like dying I mean it's like it's the
hardest thing ever and you became a
state champion yeah I was the first
state champion of my high school yeah
there's been a couple since then I mean
in a small school I mean I only
graduated like 170 kids oh and a tiny
school yeah you're the state champion
it's pretty impressive yeah and the old
man your dad who was a tough old man
yeah a tough tough guy I mean he would
whip you with a belt
well he didn't really whip yeah I got a
beaten a couple times yeah absolutely
but the belt would be like on the
doorknob and like when you messed up
like in my house I had two other
brothers he wouldn't even like he would
just like be in there and he'd like
casually just look over to just make
sure his belt was there and you were
just like oh and then you behave yeah my
father was cool listen my father was you
know listen he was he was the greatest
dad ever man was he the greatest the
greatest he was you know like you would
get a Spanky you know respect was like
the biggest word ever like you respect
listen you come in my house even in my
house now Mike you you walk in my house
I don't care who you are my kids will
get up they'll look you right in the eye
they'll shake your hand Hello nice to
meet you or anything I can get you
they're well man no yeah absolutely I'm
big with that right at one time I said
no to my dad like he's telling me like
you know I said no and he like sort of
looked at me and I took off I ran up the
stairs he came right up after me and I
slammed the door closed and locked it
and his arm came right through the door
you know like sort of like a Freddy crew
like he's looking around like trying to
yeah
in the door I'm like oh I'm like
screaming and I'm on the second floor
and I'm like how do I get out of here
[Music]
don't you ever say no to me I'm like ah
you know I didn't know and and like it
was crazy because he would never fix the
door so like growing up even like
through high school when I was big I
always had to put a poster over my door
like my buddies over and be like oh you
got a poster on the inside and the
outside of your door and it's pretty
cool I'm like oh yeah I don't look it's
real cool
when you were growing up as a kid
a long time ago Deep South right right
where'd you grow up in Mississippi
Mississippi lots of racism lots of lots
of stuff to put up with were you chased
a lot as a kid is that where you got
your great running speed uh no I was not
chased a lot as a kid but I knew uh
about racism and I knew how to deal with
it what do you mean you learned it early
oh yeah yeah because uh you know and
we're thrown at you a lot uh I'm sorry
the n-word was it thrown at you a lot
when I used to hear it yeah you did yes
by the white man yeah yeah but I I never
let that uh stop me from achieving what
I wanted to do and I wanted to uh play
professional football but you didn't
want to play football you got into
football how playing hooky you're trying
you were bad I was a bad boy and they
made you they forced you to play
football uh well after I got disciplined
then I uh the principal wanted me to go
out for the football team and I went out
and uh gave it a try and just were you
great right away no not at all when you
were how old were you when you started
playing football uh I think I was around
uh 16. you're 16 years old and your
great speed hadn't come out yet no I was
you didn't run tracks you didn't do any
of that other stuff I was a nerd oh I
was you know I was just a nerd off to
myself so you try out for the team and
it wasn't like the principal knew
something about you he was just trying
to get you off the street no he just
noticed it yeah he just noticed so I
could run fast but but the prince
Interpol puts you in this thing you're
probably belligerent at first you don't
want to play football you get on the
team you somehow make the team you must
have been scared out of your mind if
you're a nerd you got big guys chasing
you and and you can get hurt well I fell
out of my element because as a nerd I
was off to myself all of a sudden I had
to become a team player and I worked at
it and I put that extra in and I was
able to become a starter right away did
they know that you would should be a
wide receiver was that your first
position I played wide receiver and I
played defensive back what about
catching the ball physically did you
always have big humongous hands were you
good at it right away
uh not I wouldn't say I was good at it
but I I had that that little extra so
when do you start to become a star where
people don't think of you as a nerd but
you are the man when I became a starter
I noticed the females they started
looking at me in a different direction
when you say we're nerd you've never
gotten girls you've never gotten laid I
didn't know you that's right you know I
was uh you know until I was 18. 18 you
got laid uh yeah 18 because at 18 you
you start to get written up in the
newspapers yeah I I guess I uh you know
like you said I was the star I was a
star and I uh did your family because
you come from a poor family did they
start to go hmm this could be our ticket
out of here no you know Howard to be
honest with you I felt if I made it to
the pros like I could do a lot for my
family and and uh so the first thing I
wanted to do when I signed with the
Niners I bought my mom a house I felt
you were uh Angry in your career with
Deion Sanders true or false
well Dean Dion and I we uh we were very
competitive and uh he was uh
he was uh the flashy uh the flamboyant
you know type of defensive back and yes
I wanted to uh get up in the skin you
are a Class Act everyone says I try to
be a Class Act and the fact of the
matter is that Deion Sanders went ahead
uh and signed with another team and uh
he flaunted things and this pisses you
off so yeah because I think football is
a a total team sport and uh you know
Dion came to us he did some great things
on the football field he was an
excellent corner and he helped us to win
a Super Bowl but everyone made it seem
like uh it was all about Dion but you
were angry with him too that he signed
with another team after that he should
have stayed with your team and you
should have gone on to one another shot
I would I would have loved to have gone
on to win another Super Bowl it was all
about winning did you confront him did
you say to him listen [__] I don't
like you yeah do you curse by the way
I've never heard you uh curse uh yes I'm
a very I can curse I can say very uh
profound words would you ever call him a
bad man game not on radio I knew well
when he went to the Cowboys I knew it
was going to be a big time rivalry uh
you know all over again and uh and I
think so many people connected because
they wanted to see us do better and uh
and I was able to win some of those
battles
does it piss you off that the job when
you were playing for the Giants you know
they never won
Good Seasons we went to one Super Bowl
right but but then when you leave
they've win well you know what it's it's
time for everybody right an athlete you
you look great on field you're still
putting up great seasons in the ring
you're still you know you look fantastic
your body's in great shape but you know
right you know that you've missed that
step or if you've lost that step and
it's going to fall off that Cliff pretty
quickly that happened but that was the
question because did you retire too
early but that's what a lot of people
from a fan perspective probably because
I could have given you a couple of 1400
yard seasons and honestly Howard being
in New York you know I mean you I didn't
see you here a lot but I was doing media
for 10 years I was right down around the
hallway doing serious with my brother
and all these other things we're going
on we're going and they were they were
becoming more interesting to me yeah and
so I lost the passion to do what I was
you know did made a professional career
out of because I was getting beat up I
couldn't go home and play with my kids
because my knees were hurting and my
body was aching and so I said you know I
got all these other opportunities let me
do that and to be perfectly honest I
didn't think we were close as a team
right to winning a Super Bowl as a New
York Giant you had a lot of Good Will in
the sense that hey you great player
people love you this and that so when
you retire you become critical of Eli
Manning you know you're an honest guy
you said describe I'm going to talk
about what I you felt that Eli wasn't
playing up to Snuff it wasn't even about
him playing up the snuff because he was
he was gradually and almost
exponentially getting better every year
after year after year but you were
frustrated with him because of course I
was yeah of course because I was 31
years old and at the end of my career
and we we were starting Kurt Warner who
was leading us on a you know a you know
a great season Eli's first year and then
we replaced him and all of a sudden now
at 28 29 I'm starting over with the
rookie quarterback who's going to we
know he's going to get there yeah
because he has the pedigree but he's but
it's whatever it was a stupid comment
right I was trying comment I was saying
that Eli's leadership skill is because
the way he talks and the way his manner
is it's funny right it's it's not he's
awkward and uh and I'm not saying that
in a derogatory way it's it's
entertaining right I mean I mean we have
we shoot basketball on the in the in the
you know with our tape balls after we
did our did our ankles and we try to
shoot it into the you know the trash can
we'd always be rejecting each other
stuff like that one day I'm shooting at
Eli butt ass naked comes and just
rejects it right in my face I'm like
what are you doing Eli but it was funny
right right but that that was how he
engaged with folks
um but wasn't there two days later
two days later right whichever one of
these beat brag guys goes to Eli and
says Tiki said your leadership ability
is comical oh dear right it was taken
out of context unbelievably out of
context and he responded to it what did
he say you know Tiki's made that
transition he's in the media he doesn't
you know he's forgotten what what
whatever it was it created a two silos
my Silo and Eli Silo did you call him I
called him the next day and did you get
a hold of him I did not get a hold of
him I called him the next day and said
Eli I apologize you know that did not
come out the way it was supposed to
um I did not mean any offense and we
were fine it was immediate it became a
media storm for a week two weeks and
then they go through the season the ups
and downs of that 07 season we all
remember it they were playing horribly
uh at the end of the year and then they
hit that spark right right they exactly
they played the uh the New England in
pages in the preseason and the regular
season end of the season they lost
because they hung with them right right
and it gave them confidence and an
ability a belief that they could play
with anybody They Carried that through
the playoffs and then beat the Patriots
in the Super Bowl because the giant fans
booed you at some point because yeah
right because they consider you a a guy
who retired too early they're mad at you
for protecting your body and retiring
too early exactly and I missed the Super
Bowl it's like it's like a a
Shakespearean play are you hurt by that
does that affect your life not really
when you walk around the street
[__] off nicely Giants fans say I
appreciate what you did for us I think
time has made them realize you know what
I was just a great player and and the
only thing that ever hurts me is when
people are ignorant and say things like
you sucked or right you were horrible or
whatever that
diminished what I accomplished as a
player and what I did for the for the
for the New York Giants for 10 years
when you were playing when you were a
player you separated your shoulder you
went in the game anyway and you what you
did because you were tied and if you had
to catch a ball you would knock it down
with your good hand and kind of push it
into your chest and carry the ball right
well it was similar to that I mean I I
did play where you had one arm one
shoulder strapped down but you played I
mean you have a harness on it where it
couldn't move a certain way it was
harder to catch a football because only
one arm went up in the air right but you
could do it you did it but a lot of guys
what about these guys who sit out when
they have an injury the game's different
I mean it's all about money right I mean
they're going to jeopardize their career
to play one game uh in their earning
power and plus you know it it's just a
hard thing for them to do really and I'm
not sure I blame them I mean uh I can I
can get my shoulders up and it hurts you
were you were voted I guess like the
number one tight end of all time and all
that you didn't get a lot of money to
play did you I mean we were kind of my
first contract and no no that's a long
time ago no we got to put things in
perspective nice 1961 right I signed a
12 000 contract with a six thousand
dollar signing bonus that's eighteen
thousand but in Sixty one my dad worked
in a in a steel mill so you know but
what was his relative but what was the
game plan in life for you in other words
when you're making twelve thousand
dollars yeah okay that's a lot more
money than your dad was making but still
didn't you worry that you'd get out of
football who knew you were going to be
the great coach who knew what was going
to be uh what was the game plan it could
have gone horribly wrong right there was
no game plan in my life at all when I
played with the Bears just football my
game plan came into focus when I went to
Dallas for the Cowboys I played for the
Cowboys for four years we won a Super
Bowl I played for Coach Landry I coached
there for nine years as an assistant
coach and then I became the head coach
of the bear so if I would have never
went through that process in Dallas I
doubt that I would ever become head
coach of the Bears when you were a coach
for the Bears you know I always meant to
ask Jim McMahon wasn't a great
quarterback in the sense of the all-time
grades so you don't need a great
quarterback to win do you you just just
need a competent quarterback Jim McMahon
was a winner and a leader right but if
you're talking about physically he
couldn't come close to Moreno right so
wait so your point of view as a coach
now is that you give me a guy who's a
leader but he doesn't necessarily have
to be physically the best quarterback
that ever lived who throw the farthest
this and that you come up with a game
plan it's really a team sport let me ask
you something because I always wonder
what is the importance of the coach you
know like these coaches now have become
superstars of the game
well you know you're right the players
play the game you know and I said you
know you know somebody once said that
there's no coach worth a player but I
disagree with that I think that you
formulate the game plan everything in
life is a game plan what you do today
you we all have game plan and and you
know when you take a guy I go back in my
life to people I've watched Lombardi
right when he went to Green Bay they
stunk why did they change right change
because of him and what he made them
understand there's only one way to do
things that was his way it was the right
way so you know people he was a leader
and he inspired right inspiration right
he inspired him you don't motivate they
got to motivate them but also tactically
you've got to be sort of a genius you
got to sit there and go hey how am I
going to get this ball down for you well
the old thing k i s s keep it simple
stupid because it's not genius it isn't
it's beating the other guy you know what
he's doing you know what you do best but
if you're ever going to give up doing
what you do best to try to defeat the
other guy you're not going to defeat
them after an incredible career in
Chicago that you had you retired for
three years from coaching and then you
come back and you go to New Orleans was
that a mistake in retrospect I mean who
the hell you got a lot of aggravation in
New Orleans right they gave you crap not
really uh I I tell you what you know to
say why I did it I thought it was divine
intervention because you know you got to
understand now I I've been part of uh
three Super Bowl winning teams uh two
Super Bowl as an assistant coach and a
head coach and if both of them were
playing New Orleans so right I said
God's calling me to go to New Orleans
unfortunately I mean you thought you got
a sign for God
it was a short stop right but anyways no
but you hated the fans there no I didn't
never did no other fan listen they're
the greatest fans in the world they're
the most most person I mean they've hung
in there for 46 years and what happened
in that City last year well then winning
the Super Bowl was the greatest thing in
the world it was a great story Katrina
the whole thing I mean I was there
through all that stuff it was crazy
is it difficult for you to negotiate a
contract with Fox knowing how many guys
out there you know find sportscasters
want your job I've done it now for 20
plus years right you know it it's not an
easy job to do everybody's good over
here but when they're counting you down
for 120 million people to watch the
network has to know
that you're not going to [__] it up
right and if and they have to trust you
that's what they're buying with me
they're buying somebody that they know
I'm not going to make a dumb decision
this Sunday and say something that's
going to get the network in a bunch of
trouble that's that's the premium and
and that unless you've sat in that seat
you don't know what that feels like
right it is tough I mean when you have
that many people listening and who are
all experts on their own well yeah and
you've got to know something you cannot
[__] up the information no and I think
the the sports fan
in today's world is way more intelligent
than back even when I started because of
the internet because of the betting
because of fantasy football they know
people come up to they know more about
Richard probably knows more about the
Chiefs and the Royals than I do do you
study a lot I mean when I read every day
yeah you have to read every day to keep
up because you know there's there's five
stories a day the problem is when you do
a Super Bowl there's an off week
and you compile so much information
going into that game I have this board
that I make up you start piling all this
info on there and by the end of two
weeks you can't read any of it do you
have a staff that helps you with that
you know there's no time for that I mean
and I need to do it myself like I need
to put the names and numbers and Heights
weights College I have to do that myself
because if you call the wrong like you
say oh that was number blah blah you're
dead I guess for uh in 07 I did the
Giants in the Super Bowl and David Tyree
makes this catch and if there's one call
I've made that I get more trouble for
it's this catch so it's it's in the
fourth quarter it was it was an
unbelievable game it's the only time my
heart was about to jump out of my chest
doing a game because you go my God
there's a hundred million people it's
the Patriots were going for a perfect
season the Giants they're from New York
my God right it gets no bigger and Eli
Manning avoids this sack heaves it
downfield and David Tyree kind of a
third receiver makes his catch repins
the ball on his helmet I remember that
and all these arms and these bodies go
to the ground and I'm up there like
first of all I thought Manning was sack
secondly I can barely see who caught it
whose helmet is it and people are like
you didn't give that catch it's you know
it's due Mike you sit up there if I
start going oh my God an unbelievable
catch by David's it's incomplete I beg
your pardon is that you have to be sure
when you do a Super Bowl so when you're
calling the game are you watching a
monitor of the game or are you watching
the field I watch the field but the
monitor is is is in front of me to where
if the picture drastically changes I see
it and I can go to what they're showing
I mean when we do a Super Bowl I don't
know the total number but there's over
30 cameras in the stadium that are so
they can show you just about anything
the new statistician or absolutely no
yeah no there is yeah so I I do a game
and and I've got this board eye makeup
so I do all that myself but then I've
got a guy Dave schwabe Staten Island
Zone who's over my shoulder helping me
with who made the catch who made the tax
is it the greatest feeling as a man to
take down a quarterback oh my goodness
what does that feel like when you come
around that corner and you put that move
on that alignment and you're turning and
he's squared up in that pocket you know
you can't hear anything at this point
right it's like you're in a a tunnel and
it's just like that it's quiet yeah and
when you hit him and drop and you hear
that from him that's the first thing you
hear the ooh from him when you open your
eyes or you look up it's like somebody
just like took headphones off of you and
the crowd is there and chill but arguing
them now I know and the fans go crazy
and your teammates love you
they don't know what to do oh yeah they
beat you upside the head and then you're
hoping to third down so you're done but
sometimes it's second and then you got
another play so you got to bring
yourself back from that you know oh man
do you feel good like like do you do you
if you break that guy like literally
break his leg
well listen you can't control that if
you if you hit again like with the
Lawrence Taylor and um Theisman
because he wanted to take him down and
then when you and you saw Lawrence's
reaction when he jumped I'm like come
help him you don't never want that
feeling on your resume because that
ended theisman's career that was it I
mean he never really recovered God
that's that's before modern medicine so
you would feel bad doing that to
somebody oh my god did you ever end
someone's career no so have you ever
held back so that you don't you haven't
held back no so you hit him and you
hoped that you don't kill him I know
what the hidden area is but don't you
think it's a crazy sport in a sense
because a guy your size with your speed
yeah but a guy your size with with your
speed coming at that velocity and
sometimes quarterbacks are blind on
their one side to see you they go down I
mean it is a TR that's the train wreck
they go that's what I want don't you
think in a way someday football will
change and you will not be allowed to
hit the quarterback it will almost be
like two-hand touch you're gonna be okay
hit the receivers now they built the
Autobahn in the Middle Field where
you've been that's what I'm saying do
you love the game oh love it love it and
you love being a commentator you love
you you love the whole thing all of it
there's nothing better than a kid's game
doesn't it blow your mind like a guy
like Tom Brady who I'm sure you get
asked about all the time how is this guy
play season after season with so few
injuries it's almost unbelievable isn't
it I mean you get pretty damn banged up
in a football game it's crazy first of
all Lady Luck plays a role right anybody
can get hurt anybody could have an
accident the joints were designed by
Evolution or make or whatever to be
bending a certain way a knee is supposed
to bend this way back and forth not
sideways nope and when that happens
you're tearing ligaments Tom is the best
I've been asked that question for many
years and Johnny you was my hero Otto
Graham was great slinging Sammy ball I
go back you know These Guys these are
the guys you watched but meantime Tom
has been challenged more in recent
history certainly with huge games than
anyone I could recollect and he stepped
up every time unbelievable here's a
quarterback when I watch pro football
games college games you can literally
see and I actually lost games for our
team by throwing poorly throwing
interceptions I have not seen Tom Brady
lose a game for his team is he the
greatest that ever was I would have to
say he's the best at answering the
challenge there ever was yes I've not
seen anybody have that many big games
right and answer the challenge as well
as he has it's it's crazy to me I'm not
a super big knowledgeable guy about
football but when I watch this guy play
he just pulls it out of somewhere and
that's the thing how many guys did you
play with in high school who you would
even consider who were better than you
but for some reason they never make it
to the pros like what is that X Factor
that makes a guy a pro like you become
one of the Legends desire to start with
and again locked injuries come into play
and different positions some guys
physiology physically they're built to
be a center a guard a tackle and it's a
team thing the quarterback's not going
to go from here to there is do anything
without those cats blocking for him up
front right you know the best
quarterback that I know of that's not in
the Pro Football Hall of Fame and he
would be the first Manning into the Pro
Football Hall of Fame as their daddy
Archie right but he played for the New
Orleans Saints
the New Orleans ain't right they used to
wear bags over there
and Archie was running for his life all
the time
when did you decide I want to leave New
England and I want to go to a new team I
probably knew before the start of last
season that it was my last year before
last offseason I had a contract that got
restructured and then basically you know
from my standpoint
I knew that at the end of the year I I
was going to become a free agent for the
first time in my career
and I had spoken about it with the
ownership of the team Mr Kraft and he
was good with it I had spoken about it
with Coach Belichick he was good with it
and that's what we decided to do I said
this before there's no bigger fan of the
New England Patriot organization than me
you know but at the same time that
doesn't mean that I could continue to
play there at the highest level I want
to prove to myself that I still perform
at the highest level did you go over Bob
Kraft's house and sit there and say hey
uh Bob this is it we're done and and do
you call I mean where do where do you go
to make that announcement to these guys
who you've you know spent your whole
career with I called it you know Mr
craft and I and I went over to his house
and I you know and I just I went over
and I said look I just want to say you
know how much I love you and appreciate
what we've done together and I just I
know that we're not going to continue
together but thank you I was able to
call Coach Belichick at the same time
and thank him I wanted to hear from me
how was your tears you know how I
thought about yeah I was crying I mean
I'm a very emotional person you know I
have a deep caring for the people that
I've worked with and I want I wish
nothing but the best for them
I thought the saddest thing I heard
through the whole Super Bowl Gary and
John were on the wrap-up show they got
the crafts to come by and they even got
my homes to come by and they put Richard
on with my homes and you started crying
dude you are so [__] odd I couldn't
control myself oh yeah I'm gonna play it
for you oh I don't want to hear it oh my
God you're such a [__] weirdo
I get emotional like Whitney Houston
he's a baby man I'm gonna play this for
you but Richard starts crying to my
homes first of all you're like Patrick
what are you doing for Kansas and you
gonna bring the Super Bowl and you don't
know what it means for people like me it
means nothing it means a lot come on Rob
like people like you you're a guy who
got out of Kansas you work on the Howard
Stern Show you live in Manhattan that's
so great why did you leave yeah you work
in Manhattan because the show isn't
based there you're not not typical of a
Kansan so when you tell my homes people
like me how many people here you got to
hear this listen to this [__] Maniac
well I mean he's just like this amazing
Ray of Hope that you know what you've
brought to Kansas City is uh and my home
is probably thinking I gotta get off the
show I came in to have fun you know like
this [__] weird I was crying I'm
getting emotional sorry Patrick it's all
good you've just brought so much
happiness to people like me and uh you
know Chiefs fans I had so much fun
watching you this year uh and you just
mean so much to me and everybody in
Kansas City and all my friends we have a
Chiefs bar here in Queens New York that
we watch from and we just have such
comrade guys thinking to himself who is
this weirdo like I don't even want to be
in Kansas City I just got you know yeah
they hired me and you just made us so
happy this year and I I am so excited
for what's to come in the the many years
ahead so thank you Patrick no I
appreciate it man uh I appreciate
everything you said and hopefully we get
that super bowl for you here soon yeah I
hope to see you in Miami a year from now
so yeah for sure Richard you're super
close with your dad and you had told me
how you guys kind of bond over the way
Patrick plays in his whole story
absolutely I mean my dad got my dad I
was born in 74 so I didn't get to see
the Chiefs win the Super Bowl in 1970
but my dad did and my dream is for
myself and my dad to be able to watch
the the Chiefs win the Super Bowl
together
is this guy dying what what's going on
here he must have been so happy I wasn't
there live 23 years old you're like a 45
year old man so I think he's freaked out
yeah I'm right I didn't even think about
that well they asked to him it's like
who's this old [__] who's crying they
asked him if a guy's ever cried in front
of him and he said no now he has had
that happen and I know that you can make
that happen Patrick and just thank you
man we're gonna get it done for sure
we'll make that happen for sure I know
you will I know you will and that's why
I love you so much man you don't
appreciate it during this whole time how
long is my contract
I will be out of there [__] baby
you're out of your mind I can't wait I
won't argue with you Kansas I can't wait
I hope my home sleeves hey don't even
say that I hope my homes goes to like
the Jets that's so mean
laughs